think levon certainly has something
concrete in mind
concrete so his rook is under attack the
black rook
does it run away from the white king but
hang on a second
this is working this is not working or
levon iranian has just blundered and
lost
his rook he's losing the game he didn't
look at levon ironian's face he didn't
look for checks
that is so sneaky he's just pushed his
pawn forward
levon thought that okay he's attacking
the opponent's rook but with that pawn
push now next move
after black's king runs away from the
track white will just capture the black
rook with his own rook
oh and look at lavon aronian's face he
is furious with himself
now yeah absolutely i mean is it a mouse
slip or is it no no no this is
one moment of carelessness wow he just
didn't
he just didn't consider all the checks
and captures and now this is just game
over because after all
lavon has blundered his rook um
just a rock for nothing he didn't even
get a pawn in return for that rook
um he was already a point up early and
now he only has one pawn those two black
pawns easy to blockade on the dart
squares and
levon just resigns a miracle win there
from jordan
on the brink of defeat he brings it back
wow what a dramatic
start you guys to the chessable monsters
levon aronian about to win the first
game